TONY CHAN: Hi, everyone.
Sorry again for the technical
difficulty earlier.
So I hope now everyone can see
everything OK and no echo.
So let's jump straight
to the news.
So the news of this week,
so we have new devices.
So we just announced this
week, the Nexus 4.
It's a Quad core Snapdragon S4
with a Snapdragon processor
with the largest 4.7
inch screen.
And it has NFC, actually, which
is what we are going to
talk about today.
We have also another
new device.
It's a 10 inch device.
It has a super high
resolution--
it's 2560.
And so I'm sure you guys can
read more about these two
devices on the internet.
And of course, the new version
of Android 4.2, we just
announced it.
And along with that, we have
also pretty good guidelines of
how to build high quality tablet
applications, and also
in general high quality
applications.
So we added some more
documentation guidelines to
help developers to build high
quality applications.
Another major news we
have, we now have
seller support in India.
You can read more about that
in the blog post, but just
want to clarify something.
The seller support also includes
in-app billing.
And subscriptions are
also included.
The Google+ experiment
we announced earlier.
So we still need to gather
all the submissions.
And we will follow up with
you guys next week.
So stay tuned.
So now back to our
presentation this
week, which is NFC.
So let's take a look
at what NFC is.
Just before we dive into the
implementation details, so
let's take a high-level overview
of what NFC is.
So NFC stands for Near
Field Communication.
It's really based on the
RFID technology.
It's a short-range technology.
So usually when the device to
the NFC tech card is between 4
centimeters or less,
communication will start happening.
You can also share a small
payload, usually in kilobytes,
between NFC tags and an Android
device, or between
Android devices.
So the most common data format
people use for NFC is NDEF.
Also, we will talk a little
bit more about
that in future slides.
So what is NFC for?
Actually, you can use NFC
for a couple of things.
The first one is social.
I mean, you can share contact
information using NFC, which
is one of the most
common use cases.
And also, you can use NFC to do
bootstrapping for Bluetooth
and Wi-Fi connections.
So Anirudh will talk a little
bit more about that, and also
the Android technology,
Android Beam.
So Anirudh will cover
that later on.
And the third use case of
NFC is in commerce--
so for example, contact-less
payment like Google Wallet.
But that is a little bit outside
of our topic today
because Google Wallet
requires the access
to the secure element.
And if you are interested in
becoming a partner of Google
Wallet, you can go to the link
below here to send us
information.
But that's not something
we're going to cover
today, Google Wallet.
We're going to focus on
the technology today.
So for NFC, there are a few
communication protocols.
So these are the protocols.
So I'm not going to spell
out all of these
ISO standards here.
But the key thing here is we
have Android classes to talk
to these protocols.
and so I kind of highlight that
with the bullets here.
And besides the protocol,
we have different
types of NFC tags.
So the standard ones defined
in the NFC forum, there are
four major types.
And there are products,
actually, implementing these
different types.
So some of the more common ones,
probably that you guys
see most, are the MIFARE ones
and the Sony FeliCa one.
But there are four major
types of tags in NFC.
I have actually a very nice
table to summarize all these,
to put things together.
So stay tuned.
And besides the NFC forum
standards, there are also
other types of tags.
So the MIFARE Classic
one is one of them.
And it's also very popular--
NXP is using this type of tag.
And there's additional operation
you can do with
these tags.
And we have a special class,
actually, for these also,
called MifareClassic.
So what is NDEF?
So we talked about formats of
data we use in NFC, and I
mentioned NDEF is the most
common standard.
So NDEF actually stands for
NFC Data Exchange Format.
It's really a lightweight
binary message format.
And one thing about NDEF is an
NDEF message can have many
NDEF records.
And for data with an
application-defined payload
can be actually encapsulated in
one or more NDEF records.
So let's take a look at the NDEF
record, talk a bit more
about that in detail.
So an NDEF record is composed
of a header and a payload.
So in the header, it has a
3-bit Type Name Format.
And it also has the
type itself--
it's in variable length.
It's from 0 to 255 bytes.
And the same thing for the ID.
It's optional and not
very often used.
And then the payload.
The payload can actually have
data up to 2 to the power of
32 minus 1 byte.
So that's the structure
of the NDEF record.
So here's the big picture side,
a summary of all the
relationship between
all the classes.
So if you look at the NFC stack,
so you have the analog
things at the bottom.
And then you have the different
communication protocols.
And there are two
major types of
applications people can build.
So one is using the standard
NDEF message format.
And within that, you have the
NFC forum standard Type 1 to
Type 4 tag and also have
the MIFARE Classic tag.
And the stuff in blue is
actually the Android classes
we have to the implementation
for those
particular types of tags.
And for non-NDEF format
applications, we also have the
corresponding classes to allow
a developer to talk directly
through the protocol.
So we have all these NFCA class,
which corresponds to
the ISO 14443-3A protocol,
and et cetera.
So it's mapping these route
protocols if the application
is not using the NDEF
data format.
So that's a nice summary of
all these things together.
So now let's start to talk about
how Android actually
reads these tags and then how to
dispatch these tags to your
applications.
So again, the two major
categories, one is the tag
using the NDEF format, and the
other one is using the
non-NDEF format.
So we have different action
types, essentially
following the order.
We first try to see whether
something matched the NDEF
data format first.
So we have an action called
NDEF discover.
So if there is an activity that
matched that action, we
will route the intent
to that application.
So we will see some example
of how to set up these
[INAUDIBLE]
in your application later.
So back to the picture, if the
NDEF discover action, we don't
see any NDEF-format tag, we
will fall back to the tag
discover actions and then to
the tag discover actions.
So this is how the Android
decision tree to decide how to
dispatch all the NFC tag
it reads from the fail.
So now, how to request NFC
access in the application?
So as you guys probably can
imagine, this definitely has
something to do with
the manifest.
So the first thing you need
to do is to add a special
permission.
It's android.permission.nfc.
And for filtering application
in Google Play, you want to
use the feature use_feature tag
specifying the hardware.
So if NFC is really an optional
feature in your
application, you can consider
setting the required
attribute to false.
And you can also check NFC
runtime availability by using
the getDefaultAdapter()
method.
If it equals null, that means
NFC is not available in that
particular device.
So another thing is you have to
set the minimum SDK version
in your application.
So the minimum SDK version that
will have NFC support is
API level nine.
So in this level, we
will support the
ACTION_TAG_DISCOVERED action,
but we recommend developers to
at least specify level 10,
because it has a much more
comprehensive read/write
support in level 10.
And also you can do foreground
NDEF pushing.
In API level 14, we added
Android Beam support and also
some extra convenience methods
to create NDEF records.
So at least use API level 10.
That's our recommendation.
So filtering--
let's take a look at how you
set up your activity to
capture these NFC intents.
So one of the actions you
can filter by is the
NDEF_DISCOVERED action.
In this example here, you
can filter by MIME type.
So you can specify if the MIME
type is plain text, you have a
data tag and specify the MIME
type, that's how you filter
NFC message--
by MIME type.
And if you want to do
filtering by URI,
you can also do that.
So it has a different data tag,
specifying the host or
prefix of your URI.
And the next actions--
after the dispatch system
couldn't find a match on the
NDEF_DISCOVERED action, we'll
fall back to this
TECH_DISCOVERED action.
And in order for this to work,
your application has to
specify an XML resource file
to specify the list of
technology the NFC tag
you're reading--
your application--
the list of NFC technology has
to support before your
application can process the
NFC tag information.
So in this case here, what you
are trying to say here is your
application will only take NFC
tag that can support the
entire list of NFC technology.
So it's a pretty long
list of things.
I think in reality, you only
want to specify a field,
because this is really
end cases.
So you're trying to find
something that supports all of
these technologies--
it's not all.
So how to do an all
in the tag lists--
so if you specify multiple
resources, like this example
here, so you're trying
to filter something.
If the NFC tag is supporting
NFCA and NDEF and all is
supporting NFCB or NDEF, both
of them will match, and your
applications can serve both
of these NFC cards.
So if you need to use the all
semantics, this is the way how
you define the tech list.
So another fallback is using
the TECH_DISCOVERED in your
activity, you pretty much just
filter by the TECH_DISCOVERED
tech actions.
And then you add the metadata
tag, pointing to the
resource XML file.
So this is how you include the
filter in your manifest.
So did I miss--
OK.
So how to obtain information
from the intent.
So it's pretty straightforward.
There are two ways
you can do it.
If you want to have the NFC
tag, you can always do the
getParcelable data extra,
calling the EXTRA_TAG.
And it will return you a tag,
and you can just look through
and get them to find out
the list of technology.
But there's also a very
convenient way.
If you know you are only
processing NFC tech using the
NDEF data format, you can use
the NDEF_MESSAGES extra to get
a list of NDEF messages.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
here is really an example of how
you get the NDEF messages.
So you pretty much get a list
of parcelable, and then you
[? cast ?] these raw messages
to the NDEF message to just
look through it.
So the next session, Anirudh
is going to talk
about Android Beam.
So I pass it to Anirudh.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: All right.
Thanks, Tony.
So to begin with, what's
Android Beam?
It's something that's based on
something called NFC NDEF
Message Push.
So this is about pushing
messages from an app that's
running on the foreground, an
activity that's running on the
foreground to another activity
running on another phone.
So that's the push
part aspect--
TONY CHAN: By the way, can you
guys see the slide when
Anirudh talks?
MALE SPEAKER 3: I can, Tony.
TONY CHAN: Andrew, you can?
How about Andrew?
Andrew, can you see the slide
when Anirudh talks?
Andrew, can you see the slide?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: He
has a [INAUDIBLE]
message, but he can highlight
it to see.
So it's probably not
getting recorded.
Tony, let me do something.
I will share my desktop
instead.
TONY CHAN: OK.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: All right, I
think we've got my slides on
the screen now.
So as I was mentioning,
NFC is based on NDEF
message push format.
And it's basically NDEF message,
like Tony explained,
it's something that contains
zero or more NDEF records, the
first record being something
that contains the URI or the
MIME type of the content that
your NDEF message contains.
For example, if it's an image,
you would have something with
the image MIME type.
Or if you have text, you would
set ASCII as the MIME type.
So that's your zero
position NDEF
record in the NDEF message.
Now, this message with these
records is pushed from one
device when in close
proximity.
And that's the basic
concept of NFC.
When you bring devices in close
proximity and when your
app is running in foreground,
that's when NFC beam is
activated, and it tries to
push the message from one
device onto the other one.
So as a programmer, how do you
enable your app or make your
app Android Beam capable?
It's quite simple.
There are two options of
how you can do that.
The first one is, you basically
invoke the method
setNdefMessagePush().
So when your app is running,
your activity is in the
foreground, you call this
method, and this method is
usually used if you have a
static data to be pushed.
For example, you may want
to push the link
of your app to download.
And this is something static,
and this is the method you
would use when you have to
push that kind of data.
The other option is that you
can have your activity
implement something called
CreateNdefMessageCallback.
And so as soon as your activity
then comes into
foreground, the system invokes
this method, calls your
activity back using
this interface.
And the only method that you
have to implement from this
interface is the
createNdefMessage method.
So this method is where you
have to provide the
implementation of how you create
the message and return
a message from the method.
So the framework would invoke
the callback, and
this method is called.
And at this point, you
should return the
created NDEF message.
So this is more useful when you
want to add some context
to your NDEF message.
So depending on what state your
activity is, or maybe,
for example, if you're on
YouTube and you have some URL
that you're watching right now
which you want to push to the
other guy so there is
some context here.
So you would use this
implementation of using a
callback and create the NDEF
message appropriately by using
the context from your activity
and embedding that data onto
the message and parcelling
that message through.
And when this is done, what you
get is a callback called
setNdefPushCompleteCallback.
This is the callback that's
invoked when the system is
able to reliably beam the
message to the other device.
So what we've discussed here,
there's a short snippet of
code on how it's implemented--
very simple code.
OnCreate we set the NDEF
message push callback.
And this is the other
implementation, which is the
implementation of implementing
an interface callback.
So we have a method implemented
here called
createNdefMessage, which
comes from the create
NDEF message callback.
At this point, what we do is we
construct an NDEF message.
So like we said, NDEF message is
basically an array of zero
or more NDEF records.
So in this case, what we do is,
we have this method called
createMimeRecord, and this
is a custom method.
So what createMimeRecord does is
basically creates the first
NDEF record as the MIME
type of the data.
In this case, ASCII is the
MIME type because we are
sending some text across.
So what it does is puts the MIME
type as the first NDEF
record and then uses the
rest of the message--
in this case, it's just a text
that says "beam me up." And it
uses this to add to the payload
of the NDEF message,
which is the records falling
from index one, two, three,
and as long as your data is.
But the first record is
always the MIME type.
And how do you receive
this Beam message?
So what we've done
till now is we've
created the NDEF message.
And when our activity's in
foreground, the system will
try to beam this message.
So on the other device, which
is in close proximity, you
have to filter your NFC intent
ACTION_NDEF_DISCOVERED.
This will make sure that the
system knows that you have a
component or you have an
activity that's interested in
this intent.
And when you declare this
intent, you declare it with a
URL or MIME type of interest
to you, which means--
so for example, a code that we
just saw in the last slide was
trying to send you
some ASCII text.
So when you declare this in
your manifest, you may say
that I am only interested
in text.
If there's an NFC intent with
a message that's carrying
text, I'm interested.
Or if there's an NFC message
carrying some image data, I am
interested.
So you declare also your
MIME type of interest.
So again, like we said, it
should be the same as the
first NDEF record of the
incoming message.
Because that's where we kept the
MIME type of the message.
So once you do that, and let's
look at some simple code--
here it is.
This is the method that's
invoked on new intent, which
is what we'll get
called when--
[INAUDIBLE].
So this method is what we're
invoking on new intent.
And so that means there is an
incoming message now that we
are ready to process.
So what we do now is using the
GET_EXTRAS of the intent, we
try to obtain the raw message,
which is the NDEF message.
And the NDEF message is the 0th
or the beginning element
of the raw message array.
And this is the only
element right now.
So once we get the NDEF
message, what
we want to do is--
the actual message, because the
0th element is the MIME
type or the URL type, what we
want to do is get the payload
starting from the 0th message.
So we say,
ndefMessage.getRecords.
And we use the method
getPayload, which will give us
the following records from the
MIME type, following the MIME
type record.
And this is basically the text
message that we had, which
said "beam me up." And this is
how you obtain the message.
So as you can see, it's just 10
lines of code on both sides
on both devices.
And sending the intent as well
as receiving the intent, and
your app is now NFC
Beam capable.
You have some more use cases
like Tony discussed-- how to
set up a handshake for
Bluetooth with NFC.
And then in this case, you might
want to exchange some
more data of different MIME
types between the two devices
if you want to initiate a
Bluetooth connection or if you
want to send across images
or some other text data.
But in general, this
is how NFC works.
Move the MIME type under the
first record, create the other
records with the payload, and
push the payload across.
Declare the intent
NFC discovered.
And then once you have the
intent in your activity on new
intent, you try to process this
message by obtaining the
raw record and then getting the
payload from the record.
And all this happens
on foreground.
And that's how NFC Beam works.
Your app has to be
on foreground.
So just a use case here.
What may happen sometimes is
that there may be multiple
applications on the device
that may be interested in
listening to NFC incoming
messages of a
certain MIME type.
This could be very common for
something like a contact or
image or text-- there will
be multiple applications.
So if your application is
beaming that message and you
want to guarantee the delivery
of the message back to your
app on the other phone, what
you can do is use something
called Application Record,
and this is
Android Application Record--
AAR.
This is very simple
implementation.
What it does is just puts the
package name of your app in
the NDEF message.
Which basically means inside the
NDEF message, everything
is an NDEF record.
So this basically means that we
are creating an NDEF record
which contains the package
name of our app.
So this is to specifically
target your app at the
receiving end of the message.
This increases the probability
that your app will be the
first app to pick
up the message.
Or your app is the intended
receiver of the message.
So just to summarize what we
saw in terms of a graphical
illustration, on the top you see
a device that has the Beam
foreground UI activated, which
means the device is ready to
beam a message.
At this point, we use the
createNdefMessage method from
the createNdefMessage callback
interface to create our
message and send it
to the system
adapter, the NFC adapter.
So once you create the message,
this message is
beamed to the other device
using NFC technology.
And if you have the intent
ACTION_NDEF_DISCOVERED on your
app, this message will be
delivered to your app.
And the format of the NDEF
message would indicate what is
the MIME type or the nature of
the data in your message.
And based on this, you will have
your intent [? filter ?]
declaring those MIME types.
And once you receive the data,
you're able to pass it getting
the raw record and then
looking to the
record for the payload.
So this pretty much summarizes
what we have to offer for
Android Beam right now.
Yeah, that wraps up our live
presentation for today.
So Tony, we can move to Q&A?
TONY CHAN: Yeah, sure.
So Let's take a look at the
questions we have on moderator.
So the first one I see is from
Anatole from Ukraine.
So I need to authorize users,
but I don't want them to fill
in some data manually.
So after receiving a
confirmation email, I want
Excel in my app to be started.
Can you use URI like this?
My app colon-slash-slash some
data in Gmail client because
it knows the URI.
So we talked about
intent filter.
And I believe in the Gmail
client, actually, the standard
HTTP URI is actually working.
And so in your applications, one
suggestion I can think of
is you can have an intent filter
actually filter by some
specific URL.
So if you have some URL only
your application can
understand, so you can use
that to filter by that.
So you don't need to use a
different kind of scheme.
So that would be
my suggestion.
Anirudh, do you have anything
to add on top of that?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yeah, I think
that's the easiest way-- to go
through something that the
framework already understands.
And what the Gmail understands
is the HTTP URI.
The other thing I could think of
is maybe your confirmation
could come as a file which is
off your application type.
And once the user downloads the
file, maybe a patch, an
unlock patch or something.
When the user downloads that
file, your app is registered
to open the file of that type.
That may be another way
of handling this.
TONY CHAN: Cool.
So the second question we have
here is, anything new about
NFC in 4.2 API level 17 that you
are allowed to talk about?
So I haven't seen actually
anything I am aware of that's
super-new on 4.2.
So I need to double
check that.
And if we have something that
we can talk about, maybe we
can talk about that in
future [INAUDIBLE]
class.
So yeah.
So why don't you take
the next question?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So the question
is from Flight
Engineer, Austin, Texas.
And the question is, I would
like to replace the incoming
call screen with a
small overlay.
But it appears that there is no
way to disable the default
incoming call screen
in [INAUDIBLE]
app.
Any creative ways of achieving
the desired result?
Requiring root is
a possibility.
So I would not comment on what
you can achieve by rooting
because I'm not really
familiar.
And it's not something we
recommend anyway to our users.
So yes, you are right.
The phone application is the
standard application.
And you can't put textual
or graphical canvas
overlays over top of it.
TONY CHAN: This is really
for security reasons.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yeah,
pretty much.
TONY CHAN: Yeah, the fourth
question is coming from
Russia, from [INAUDIBLE].
So I have a positive experience
on Android platform
for porting application built
on frameworks like Spring,
Hibernate, AOP, et cetera.
I would like help to continue
development in cooperation in
this field with you.
So that doesn't really
seem like a question.
But we are glad, actually, that
you have good experience
with porting applications.
Feel free to leave us some more
comments or some specific
questions in G+ in the future
if you have anything.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yeah.
Just add something to it.
I think there are some open
source projects that are
catering to these frameworks
or applications of these
frameworks on Android.
I surely know there
is something
called Spring Android.
And definitely [INAUDIBLE].
So there is [INAUDIBLE]
or something like that available
for Android.
And these are open source.
So I think a good avenue for
you would be to work with
these guys.
Spring Android is a project
where you can go and
contribute.
And yeah, so this is how
you can work with
community that's one idea.
TONY CHAN: Anirudh, want
to take the next one?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yes.
So the next question is from
Shoshanka, Hyderabad, India.
The question is, I need the
process of changing the bite
rate of an audio file which
should be used on Android SDK.
So the question is not
really clear to me.
So I get the first part, the
process of changing the bit
rate of an audio file.
So we have media codecs where
you can have an input buffer
and an output buffer.
And you can specify the media
properties there.
But I don't get the part where
you say which should be used
on Android SDK.
Do you mean what should work
on the Android OS?
See, I'm not really clear.
Maybe if you can drop us a
comment on what you want to
say with the second part of
your question [INAUDIBLE].
But just in case, for handling
the audio and video pipelines,
you can use a media codec,
which is available on the
Android SDK.
TONY CHAN: So the next
question is from
Sweden, from Mac 10.
So random users of my apps,
maybe one user a day out of
200,000, get a Java
I/O [INAUDIBLE]
exception permission denied
when calling contacts open
file input.
A few seconds later, the
file reading works.
So Mac and I actually took a
look at the links you have.
And if doesn't actually give
us too much information.
Maybe we really need to look
at some code before we can
fully answer this.
But one idea I can think of may
be, is it possible to have
some sort of raising
conditions?
Like, the file it's actually
reading doesn't exist in
certain cases?
So that's my guess.
How about you, Anirudh?
Anything you can think of?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Not really.
I saw the [? stack list ?]
there.
Maybe if you can obtain a
buttress from the device which
will capture more information
on what's happening there.
I can see there is a permission
denied by the Unix
APIs there.
But yeah, a buttress would
probably help narrow in on
what's happening, if you can
grab one from your users.
Maybe even random failure of
flash drive or storage.
TONY CHAN: So how about
the last question?
Anirudh, do you want
to take that?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: All right.
So the question is, what are the
various best approaches to
develop static pages?
Each page contains text--
TONY CHAN: Oh, I think
you skipped one.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So that's
the second to last.
Is card emulation supported?
If yes, then how do we do card
emulation of Android devices?
Google Wallet is able to do.
Why not others?
I don't know the answer
to this one.
So Google Wallet--
I don't know.
Tony, do you have any insights
on how NFC is working?
TONY CHAN: I believe, actually,
emulation is supported.
Because I heard developer
has done that before.
And also, when one Android
device is talking to another
Android device, it's really
some sort of emulations.
But I'm not 100% sure, is it
really the true emulation?
I don't have a direct answer.
So maybe we can take a
look at that and get
back to you next week?
Follow up with you?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Also, I believe
Google Wallet is
probably not using stable
interfaces right now to work
against NFC, in the sense which
can be published as part
of SDK [? enabled ?].
Everyone's sort of experimented
in what it's doing.
And once we have some kind of
stable interface, that may
become a public SDK
[? facing the API. ?]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
The APIs that we are talking
about, I'm referring to seek
interface, which has been
provided already, has been
implemented in many of the
devices, such as the Samsung
and Sony devices--
The seek interface.
What we find is that it is not
getting implemented in the OS.
That's why it's not a standard
[INAUDIBLE].
Just hoping to get some kind of
info if it is going to be
standardized in the
future anywhere.
Is it there in the roadmap or
not-- something like that?
Because people want
to do something
with the seek interface.
They want to access the SIM
card for certain reasons--
because a secure element
has the [INAUDIBLE].
They want to access the
secure element.
And being not able to do it is
a limitation for many of the
applications.
So looking forward, is there
any plan like that that you
guys are having?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yeah.
I mean, definitely there's
work in progress--
even [INAUDIBLE]
when it was launched.
And even now, it was under
specific devices.
Because like you said,
it's not a stable
interface right now.
There are different
implementations that cross renders.
And so this is something that
is being worked at.
And I don't know the timelines
on when we'll have something
stable to be exposed
as a backward
compatibility for our time.
But there's work in progress,
and I can try to find out more
from the teams and update
you on what progress is
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Also a
small question.
Google Nexus S used to have
compatibility with the [? SWP ?]
chip, so it was able to have
a communication over there.
The previous one, the Nexus 3,
which [INAUDIBLE], there is a
[INAUDIBLE]
having it.
Are we expecting this to
be there in Nexus 4?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Sorry, can you
repeat the first part?
I didn't really catch with
the audio breaking.
AUDIENCE: I'm saying Galaxy
Nexus was not having it, yet
Nexus S, the previous one was
having the seek interface.
It was having the SWP chip, by
which the SIM can communicate
on the NFC level.
Is there any possibility that
Nexus 4 will be having it?
Is there any chance--
do you have it on the roadmap?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: I
can find out.
I can find out.
I don't know the answer.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So maybe
you can join us next
week for the answers.
Or we'll try to post it to
G+ on the [INAUDIBLE].
TONY CHAN: Yeah, try to post
the question in G+ to us so
that we have a record.
And we can follow up easier.
So thanks.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: My ID
is Anirudh Dewani.
And that's Tony Chan.
So you can find us on G+.
And maybe you can just tag us to
post a question, and we'll
[INAUDIBLE].
TONY CHAN: So let's take a look
at the last question.
So what is the best approach
to develop static pages?
Each page contained text
and optional images.
I'm thinking to use one activity
ViewPager use as your
[INAUDIBLE]
pages of a real book while the
user flips left and right
through pages of data.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So depending on
the size of the book that
you're talking about, 200 pages,
maybe, you don't want
200 fragments sitting
in a ViewPager with
data flipping across.
So what you probably want to
do is instantiate something
with five fragments and try to
buffer or cycle through your
content of the book so keeping
some pages in the buffer so
user can go up and back.
And then maybe use just
animations on a given fragment
or a view to have the content
of the fragment being
replaced, the text and the image
being replaced from your
data source again.
I mean, the strategy of using an
activity of a fragment and
some animations would be good.
So Google Books itself was
written within the script.
And the script is a low-level
graphics and mathematical
computation library that
we introduced.
So I'm not sure what the kind
of development you see on it
going ahead.
But that's what Google
Books was using at
that point of time.
But again, you have the options
using Java, OpenGL 3-D
interfaces and to give those
effects and animations.
And even the framework object
animated properties can give
you animation to give
the effect.
But yeah, I would look at
a fragment with a view
containing text and images and
some animations there.
TONY CHAN: Well, I guess
that's all we
have in terms of questions.
And so thank you very
much for watching.
And I hope you learned something
about NFC today.
So we will be back next week.
Hopefully Ankur will
be back too.
Anyway, anything else you
want to add before we--
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Just a reminder
that we are running
the Android experiments.
And the first one was about
connectivity API.
So if you have some last minute
submissions, please go on.
And if you want to showcase your
call of have us review it
or showcase what you've done,
please submit it to the
Android Experiments page.
We're looking forward to it.
TONY CHAN: Cool.
All right.
I think that's it.
Thank you very much
for watching.
And we'll see you next week.
All right.
Bye.